the Modern Warfare 2 Beta is over and we
at Gamespot have some thoughts some good
thoughts some bad thoughts some ugly
thoughts and some mid thoughts so we
kind of wanted to go through everything
that we got to check out in the beta and
give you a breakdown of what's good what
isn't but anyway joining me is David
Amani what's up and let's get right to
it so I think the first thing we should
start with is presentation sure this is
a next gen Call of Duty but how do you
think it looks I think it looks fine if
you really enjoyed Modern Warfare 2019
you will feel right at home with modern
warfare 2. there was some really cool
kind of like quality of life stuff on
the presentation like there was an fov
slider which was nice it looks really
good graphics are clean and it looks uh
it looks solid although I want to say
that as long as a game is kind of cross
gen it's going to be hindered just a
little bit a little bit yeah you know
what I mean so and and it definitely
seems that way I mean I will say this
engine that they updated or built out
for Modern Warfare 2019 is really good I
think and I think I think the lighting
shines the visuals look great but I
think the real show stopper for me was
the sound design and the sound design
has gotten a lot better over the years
with Call of Duty games but uh it's
really good in this I love firing those
guns with with the recoil when you put
on a silencer they sound different
depending on where you are like there's
that one level I think it's like the
market I spent a lot of time there
trying to capture you know the e-flag
when you're playing domination that's
how I know it all too well yeah
absolutely getting grenaded and killed
yeah or me grenading and killing other
people yeah right for me it's just me
grenading myself but that's you know
I've yeah I did that too a couple times
um but yeah I would say the presentation
is definitely a highlight for me I mean
presentation is only one thing and it
doesn't really determine whether or not
the game is good but I think if you're
the type who is more into modern warfare
as opposed to Vanguard or especially
Black Ops I think I prefer this sort of
realistic looking style it feels a
little less arcady gameplay wise but but
I think the the visuals reflect that
that uh that authenticity oh yeah that
grittiness you know yeah yeah it's
definitely there for sure well so what
we're doing is we're doing like a good
bad mid ugly list where would you
categorize this you'd say would this
fall under the good aspect of Modern
Warfare I would say for me this is good
I would say it's good this is what I
wanted this is what I was hoping I mean
visuals probably aren't going to blow
you away uh at least in multiplayer I'm
sure campaigns got some cool surprises
which we haven't seen yet but I think I
think if you like this style this is
this is a good thing yeah yeah for sure
I mean it checks all the boxes right so
I don't think there's any debate that uh
presentation I would put in a good
category absolutely okay so then let's
move on to gameplay this is this is the
meat of the discussion I imagine so this
plays a lot like modern warfare 2019
there are some new additions that we
should talk about dolphin diving being
one of them which to be fair not new to
Call of Duty been around in different
games they took it out of 2019 and it's
back does it need to be there how do you
feel about it I mean you know the more
gameplay mechanics that you have the
better right I mean there's nothing uh
putting dolphin diving back in doesn't
really take away from the game in any
way you know so it seems perfectly fine
and if you're really good at it it can
help heighten your gameplay you can get
out of uh you can get out of fire if you
are about to get gunned down and just
dive around the corner and it does feel
a little balanced because if you
suddenly dive you can't just like
immediately ready your gun start
shooting there's like that weird almost
like a grace period where you're kind of
stuck so you have to be very cognizant
of when you decide to dolphin dive
um but it's also just kind of fun to do
like if you just dolphin dive off a roof
or if you dolphin dive over like some of
the smaller uh Rubble uh it just it
feels good I don't know I like it I like
running around I like you know being a
bit of a hero in Call of Duty yeah and
so that just kind of like adds to that
uh to that element of it a little bit I
think yeah it's nice to have I feel like
I'm a bit more of a it's weird to say
purist because this stuff has existed
for a long time but I kind of don't like
it when I I start seeing this Call of
Duty milsim game where people are just
diving around [ __ ] and
people like it that's cool uh I I've
used it from time to time but I I much
prefer sliding and the other thing too I
think this kind of goes back to the
balance is that when you slide your
weapon holster cooldown is slower right
you slide you can start shooting then
right um as opposed to Dolphin diving
where you physically put your gun away
and dive stomach onto the ground and
then you have to ready your gun again
right so it feels fair in that sense and
then but this goes back to the guns too
right I think the guns I think feel
really good like I love the way they
feel there's a lot of kick especially if
you haven't tuned them correctly with
different attachments but yes but when
you mix the the weightiness of the guns
with the sound design and and the
movement I think it feels pretty good I
know you had some issues with the kick
it early on though it took a minute for
me to adjust because like you said that
recoil that kick was heavy and even on
our live stream our chat was noticing
they were like yo this this recoil is a
little too much you know
um but after a while you get used to it
and it does add a little bit of realism
to it and of course a lot of those guns
that I was using where the kick felt so
severe those were like the base model of
the guns where I hadn't really unlocked
any of the attachments or you know the
barrels and things like that
once I started tweaking them a little
bit
um and I got used to it it felt good
really when you weigh the time to kill
the shorter time to kill in Modern
Warfare with the kick I think it makes
sense I think if there was a longer time
to kill I'd probably have an issue with
the kick as well but one thing I like
about this and I liked about 2019 and
the sort of mil Sim style they push with
the modern warfare games is that if I'm
accurate you know I only need to get a
couple shots on them before they drop I
think the even shorter time to kill
makes a lot of sense with these weapons
I think overall the game feels pretty
good
um one other thing to bring up is all
the gadgets they've added a lot of
gadgets I feel like in Modern Warfare
2019 the gadgets were kind of light it
was like you got a couple grenades you
got your stem your stem text your frag
grenades your your thermal I think there
was a thermal grenade and then you've
got C4 and stuff but now I've got some
they got some weirder stuff in play yeah
they do they do they got they got some
really fun ones some that I didn't
really uh understand until I was on the
receiving end of one for example the
drill charge which is just
Delight it is so good especially if
you're able to uh to get kind of
creative with it but I I personally
really really love uh some of these new
gadgets and messing around with it
because like the the larger and more
diverse sandbox you have the healthier
and more uh longevity you have in the
multiplayer I feel like you know yeah
and so uh with the drill charge in
particular that thing is just hilarious
um you know you can go through walls you
can kind of be smart about it if you
know someone is on like a second level
or just camping behind a wall you can
completely you can basically punish them
for it which always feels great but
there are some other gadgets that I
really like specifically the DDOS I
think the DDOS is really cool and um
being able to kind of scramble people's
Radars and disable some of their gadgets
there was a moment when someone had this
like remote drone bomb and I was able to
disable it and that felt really cool but
uh it didn't completely destroy the
thing and after like six seconds the
Drone reactivated and then blew me up
anyway which sucked but whatever
um but yeah no I I think it's really
cool and uh the perks are not the perks
but the gadgets they have different
cooldowns there's tears so you have
certain uh gadgets that yeah it shows
more often you've got your primary which
is like your grenades you've got your
secondary which is like your flashbangs
and you've got your equipment the
equipment which which is what you're
talking about with the DDOS right
exactly yeah and there's also the um the
the decoy which is something that I
don't think I thought would be useful at
all but it actually ended up being kind
of fun it's really really fun and really
funny I mean that that Decoy um for one
you know it's almost like a pro tip if
you use that Decoy and there's an enemy
near you the decoy will actually pop up
in the direction of that enemy so you
can almost use it as like a little
Sentry point to kind of like see where
an enemy is coming from but uh also
hilariously you can kill yourself with
the uh the D chord W which is great uh
yeah that thing I love it it's so good
seeing that is a good sign it means
they're like you're saying it's going to
be more of a Sandbox there's a little
more malleability to how you can explore
these Maps I do well we'll get into the
maps later but there are some things
that kind of wish were different and how
the shops were designed yeah but I I
would say taking a step back uh what are
your what are your thoughts on gameplay
this for me is good as well yeah yeah
not really a second thought I think I
think gameplay is good I think maybe if
you're more into the arcadey style Call
of Duties like Black Ops
maybe you won't like it as much yeah uh
I don't like that so I'm this is I feel
like I'm at home again yeah it feels
good so moving on we've got maps and
level design oh how'd you feel about
that what'd you think of the level
design overall was there any maps that
really stood out to you so the one that
stood out to me not necessarily my
favorite but the one that stood out to
me was the Museum map because that was
the main map where it kind of encouraged
you to go uh to like the second floor
there was like multiple levels to that
map and I think
um the different game modes made that
map shine there was like a hostage
Rescue game mode where we got that map a
few times during our gameplay and the
way that I would run through that map
um it just kind of changed from round to
round there were some hallways that
didn't make sense there were some um
lanes that were just abandoned people
would take fire fights to like a
specific section
full open section to I don't know I
guess not to the right of the map East
maybe yeah yeah that was just completely
abandoned right ever used that uh
because on the other side there was just
there was just a nice spot where you
could stand and just pop anyone here yes
that way so that side felt kind of
useless to me yes
um I I didn't care much for the Museum
map I think that was probably my least
favorite map in Nevada although I will
say when we did some of the other modes
um like hostage rescue or prisoner
rescue it was definitely more
interesting there because I felt like
that more
open style map gave us more options but
yeah even then I think it's more the
aesthetic that I didn't really like it
was just too too clean it felt like I
think someone brought it up that it just
felt like a building in Battlefield
where yes
yeah and there's just one there's like
one desk in this room and it's clean
everywhere right right so like I kept
expecting walls to break or something
but nothing happened
also I mean for the beta we had a lot of
maps just
repeating round after round after round
so I mean I think that might contribute
to us getting a little sick of it like
form 19 I was feeling really good about
it in the beginning especially that
middle kind of like cluttered maze area
because I had the overkill perk so I had
a shotgun as my secondary
and I would run around popping kills
with like my you know Auto rifle or
whatever assault rifle and then I would
go inside swap to the shotgun and just
clean house and I felt great by the like
fifth time I was on that map I was done
I was like I'm over this that's my
favorite map in the beta really because
I it it had that like traditional
three-lane approach to the map where it
was like there's the building in the
center there's the training ground or
whatever to the left and then to the
other side there's that run down
building where you can kind of provide
OverWatch for both sides and I thought
that was really neat yeah I thought it
was like there was plenty of different
Avenues and I loved how when you take
the middle route where B is if you're
playing domination it was like a little
mini maze in there where you could
outplay out outmaneuver enemies inside
there as well as outside and it felt
good for snipers it felt good for close
range it felt good for mid-range I I
thought that map in general was pretty
good there weren't any avenues that I
wasn't really using I would say the one
building where you can kind of support
both sides I didn't go into a whole lot
but I think more that was through the
fact that I just didn't get a sniper
rifle in this beta except for the one
you start with I think if I had
something like that I may have spent
more time there yeah but even when
people were there I didn't feel like I
was just being pinned down by a sniper I
felt like I actually could respond and
take out those those people providing
OverWatch or whatever for sure yeah yeah
so overall how are you feeling about the
maps and these are just the 6v6
domination maps not we're not talking
about ground war yet right right so 6v6
domination Maps those Close Quarter Maps
I feel pretty good about them although I
have I'm starting to fall a little bit
to the meh you know aspect of uh of some
of these Maps I think it's more of the
more that I play the maps the more
likely it is that I could get tired of
them is yeah but I'm sure at launch
we're gonna have a larger variety of
different maps and that's going to keep
me satiated for a long time so yeah I'm
I'm kind of feeling the same I think I'm
I'd probably put this in the mid section
I would say just because I'm kind of
sick of the three-lane structure of a
lot of these maps and that was one thing
I liked about 2019 was that it felt like
they were moving away from that right I
remember interviews they said they were
trying to approach it like modern
warfare where it was more Point control
as opposed to three lanes now I get why
most people prefer three lanes it forces
you to be a little more Dynamic a little
more active and how you're maneuvering
these Maps I think that's probably why I
liked Farm 19 sure yeah in El Mercado is
that I felt like there were viable spots
for me to kind of not hunker down
because I I can't stay still for too
long but at least spots where I could
regroup kind of figure things out uh
plan my my strategy so yeah I'd I'd say
a mid on the maps so far I I imagine
when we get more maps it'll feel more
diverse and I probably won't get sick of
them I really don't want to play Museum
when this comes out I really don't want
to play more Museum I think I'm good
there okay
aggression system oh God
so we're gonna do this in two parts we
got progression system and gunsmith okay
okay so progression system overall how
are you feeling I think this is the most
confusing aspect but we got a lot of
pushback in the video you did people
were like yes oh you guys just don't get
it we get it all right
but that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
it's good right right it does not mean
that it's good I'm I'm very much mad on
the progression on the one hand the to
um you know kind of like
to kind of gas it up a bit I do feel
good about the amount of XP that I get
after a round it's very generous
especially if you have a really good
round there were times where I think I
unlocked like where I got to weapon
level like 20 after one round because I
just like popped off and I was like oh
my God this feels great you know you see
the bar fly up and you get all these uh
attachment unlocks it's that second step
that throws me off you know what I mean
like the unlock part of it is just play
the game which is simple enough you do
that passively but the moment that I um
had to start like tweaking you know
things and using the things that I'd
unlocked it that's when I started kind
of like you know taking a step back and
zoning out a bit and being like Oh my
God it didn't help that you and the beta
and I'm sure this is just a beta problem
but any time that one of us in our party
kept trying to like mess with their
stuff and their setup and and get pulled
out you would get pulled out it happened
like
from being in a Lobby to starting a game
I got pulled out like three or four
times it's like you know what I'm just
gonna wait until the game starts and I
will trick out my weapon when I get in
there because I am tired of being
exactly and that's and that's so
frustrating really you know and so
that's that's kind of where I'm at you
know with that first part of progression
where it's like yeah it feels nice to
unlock it but there's got to be a more
cohesive second half to it you know yeah
to be able to use it what about you I I
think I agree for the most part I will
say there are things I really appreciate
about it like I like that I'm not
leveling up every gun for the same
attachments over and over again it's
very nice that I can unlock
a scope that will work on other stuff or
a reflex sight now the thing that was
kind of weird and confusing was I spent
probably the first three hours not
having a reflex or a Dot site Red Dot
site turns out I had to use a uh a SMG
to unlock it and I couldn't find where
that information was I'm sure if I sat
there and dug through menus I I would
have and that would have been cool but
also like I just want to know like when
I go to it tell me how to unlock it and
maybe it did stay somewhere in there but
I felt like there was just a wall of
text on any of like the gunsmith stuff
like it was even to the point where like
some weapons would say yeah you unlock
at level 22 or whatever and then other
weapons wouldn't say it and it's because
you unlocked a receiver and there was
also this progression tree that would
show you like the path you needed to go
in order to unlock which guns which look
I think the idea of swapping out
receivers is cool I really like that as
someone who is into firearms and video
games and and that kind of stuff I think
that's cool it makes sense logically but
I think for in a video game sense it
seems really weird and it seems it seems
a little more complicated than it needs
to be I'm sure when it comes out and I
get the hang of it this won't be as much
of an issue but right now
I think it could use some adjustments
sure make things a little more clearly
put the information that I need front
and center for sure I mean the
progression tree was a little odd at
first I know like you mentioned in the
last video that I made there were folks
in the comments that were saying no the
progression tree totally makes sense
like using an lmg receiver totally makes
sense to unlock the M16 or whatever and
I can totally see that point there was
some confusion for me because I am a
casual I I am a casual when it comes to
Firearms get out of here I I am a I'm a
gamer and a gamer only you know and so
when it comes to
uh you know there was this one other
progression tree to unlock I believe it
was the SMG and you had to use uh like a
battle rifle I didn't get that at all
that made no sense to me you know what I
mean yeah and so at that point not only
does it not make sense but you start to
feel a little bit of frustration
um because you just want to you just
want a clear path to unlock uh you know
the the SMG or whatever and it just felt
like that progression uh tree that
progression system was kind of working
against me okay so before we move on to
gunsmith progression system how do you
feel good bad mid medley I'm mid I'm mid
I'm mid to bad actually if I think about
it I I think I'm bad I think I'm bad on
the progression system however I think
gunsmith is still really good well the
UI is messy I think the the main appeal
is still there and the more
customization is better for sure yeah
yeah I mean being able to Tinker with
your weapons is always a good thing you
know what I mean whether if it's making
like a Frankenstein gun that could defy
The Meta I mean there's there's a
possibility there that's a lot of fun
especially for those uh players out
there that love tinkering and creating
and making their own concoction kind of
like making a gun their own I think the
gunsmith is a great tool for that the
problem is that I have such a tough time
tied with the progression trying to
navigate all those unlocks into the
gunsmith that it makes it hard for me
but I do like I do like messing and uh
with stuff and customizing it and I also
like that you can't just overload your
gun there's like a limit five
attachments that's right back in our day
we can only put one attachment on guns
remember that Modern Warfare the first
one one attachment I think there was a
perk that let you put two and it was
like oh and I remember I remember when
the original Modern Warfare 2 came out
people were mad that you'd be able to
put a high-powered scope and a
suppressor on a sniper because that
seems overpowered oh my God look at
where we are now we just dated the hell
out of ourselves
but yeah I think you know as you said UI
issues aside gunsmith is still great I I
love messing with that kind of stuff I
like I said going back to the receiver
stuff I like that that's right in there
that I can just swap right into an SMG
true lmg right on the Fly
um because at the end of the day
honestly probably my favorite thing
about Modern Warfare and about this is
just messing with different guns making
different builds and I think it's pretty
powerful I think there's a lot of uh
unique attachments that could hopefully
change how you interact with these
different weapons I'm also like you said
I'm excited to make some just busted ass
weapons not even like op just weapons
that make absolutely no sense and then
we can throw them at uh at our Firearms
yeah Jonathan Ferguson and he can tell
us how dumb they are let's be honest
that's always the best yeah
uh see gunsmith how you feeling I think
I think I'm mid for gunsmith mostly
because the UI it was funny I was I was
gonna say bad in the beginning but you
kind of warmed me up to it I think I
think mid is is correct third person
mode the other big thing they added so
once again this is not new they added it
in Modern Warfare 2. I didn't like third
person mode in Modern Warfare 2 2009 I
don't like it now uh I think it's weird
that when you hit L to zoom in it goes
to first person mode I kind of wish it
was just a closer over-the-shoulder look
all right like like a the division or
something even you know what I mean like
there is something cool about third
person being able to shoulder swap being
able to kind of like three peek over
walls you know it adds a different
Dynamic to firefights I get it but the
moment that I'm able to zoom in and I
always zoom in it just doesn't make
sense anymore also your guy kind of runs
a little weird doesn't he like in third
person the way he's like almost like
does this yeah shimmy waddle like I
don't I don't care for third person my
my guess this is a guess but I think
they added it so they can put it in war
zone at some point have like third
person servers because if you look at
the Battle Royale landscape apart from
Apex you know I landscape fortnite's
third person that's their main
competitor I imagine with Warzone I
imagine third person is there for that
and to be fair I'd be interested in
trying out a third person war zone
because you know that map is Big it's
nice to be able to see more three Peak
and warzone
probably a little broken but could be it
could be good to have I mean that was a
strategy and Pub G that I had back in
the day where it's just I'm not gonna
peek because I don't need to I'm just
gonna hang right here and I'm gonna look
at the right of my screen and see where
y'all are coming from yeah yeah fortnite
feels like a good third-person game you
know a lot of these third person games
that are designed to be third person
feel good this feels
I don't know it feels like a little
weightless it's weird to describe it
just doesn't doesn't quite feel right so
for me this is this is probably an ugly
or a bad situation I completely agree I
I do want to point out though that you
had a incredible point because I did not
think about the uh potential of War Zone
2.0 having a third person mode that is
very astute and I think in Warzone 2.0
we could look at that and be like this
is pretty novel and cool in the you know
beta and the base game mode unnecessary
I think it's ugly too yeah all right so
before we wrap up what's your overall
feeling on this beta good mid bad ugly
it is a in between mid to good to me I
think that there is enough good in this
beta that it gave me what I expected
what I want uh and if anything it made
me hungrier for the final release yeah I
think I'm same spot as you I think I
think I'm good mid I think
that will definitely change when there's
more maps in rotation because for sure
as much as I did like Farm 19 and El
Mercado I was getting sick of some of
them and I'd like to just see what else
is on offer so yeah good mid hell yeah
all right well why don't you let us know
what you think of the Call of Duty
Modern Warfare beta if you got to play
it or uh let us know what you think when
it comes out comes out what October 21st
for single player October 28th for
multiplayer yes and November something
for war zone war zone and DMZ 2.0 so we
got a ton of Call of Duty stuff coming
your way for the rest of the year so
make sure to subscribe if you haven't
already and stay tuned to GameSpot